also ich find das design echt cool es
ist ganz simpel und das c steht für
contra ftr clown küche meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft es heute am 22
dezember ich habe mir gedacht ich nehme
wieder eine folge minecraft fries auf
heute finden 22 noch übermorgen für den
24 weil nicht jeden tag eine folge
kommen kann weil ich ja richtig viel
vorproduziert und ihr seht schon hier
sind ein paar neue sachen gebaut worden
und zwar ist dass jemand eine etwas
andere folge also ich wollte jetzt nicht
irgendeine 15 minuten folge machen wo
ich die ganze zeit irgendwelche fragen
beantworte das wird in der folge
übermorgen sein die wird dann auch so
ein bisschen so revue passieren sein
also diese folge und übernächste werden
nicht so lange sein sondern mehr so ein
bisschen dass ich mich den lava und so
und zwar wollte ich euch nur eben die
sachen zeigen die ich oft screen gebaut
habe und zwar bin ich ja zurzeit wenn
ihr das video seht schon einen tag im
urlaub in österreich und ich habe das
video dann erhalte ich habe mal die
ganzen videos bearbeiten österreich man
die kommen und weiter jedenfalls ist es
halt so dass ich dann die ganzen videos
als auch immer rändern muss dann das
dauert halt seine zahlen während diesen
renner vorgänger habe ich dann immer
halt nebenbei so ein bisschen minecraft
fries gezogen habe ich zum beispiel so
ein paar sachen gemacht wie ihr seht
schon diese geschenke hingestellt das
ist einfach netter reck also ich hab
hier erst mal war ich in der höhle und
habe mir obsidian geholt dann habe ich
hier so ein portal gemacht und ich habe
einfach viel zu viel obsidian abgebaut
weil ich immer so linksknick geduld
links links links links habe ich mal so
gedrückt gehalten um die gal abzubauen
und direkt auf mein video geschaut und
hab dann einfach viel zu viel abgebaut
deswegen das sonnen kein zombie sein
sondern einfach ein ja sein herz und
wenn wir jetzt mal in den neckar gehen
seht ihr auch schon da die muss eine
kartoffel essen
die spinne was will die denn wenn die
mich jetzt nieder aber geschubst hätte
elters wer mal richtig traurig und zwei
abstand hier einfach richtig viel dreck
abgebaut ist ein bisschen was abgebaut
ich glaube das war gar nicht hier
sondern ich bin so ein bisschen nach
hinten gegangen hab damit etwas abgebaut
überall aber das ist noch recht normal
aussieht
natürlich nicht mit den pixies angelegt
ich habe sogar noch ein bisschen netter
recken im inventar ihr wisst ja man kann
doch diese server nicht in den game mode
wechseln deswegen hier bin ich dann raus
gekommen das war von ihm gehen die höhle
dagegen hier irgendwie hoch und anspornt
man da das ist halt die kacke wo ich
ganz am anfang
gespannt bin wo ich als erstes mein
lager aufstellen wollte total darsteller
das jetzt einfach die sonne untergeht
und ich jetzt dementsprechend einfach
dass in zehn jahren zu hause bin
obwohl er so weit ist das gar nicht ich
kann sogar schon da hinten den
schneemann entdecken und so das ist
schon krass wie sich die welt quasi
expandiert hat und zwar im ich wollte
heute eigentlich nur halt eben diese
sachen bei uns muss ich hier fast gar
nicht guck mal da oben ist groß
allerdings an an dem an dem
weihnachtsbaum von kef gefällt mir nicht
richtig war was da gebaut hat das meist
aber meine ich auf screen oder also
keine ahnung
jedenfalls habe ich hier dann im all
diese geschenke gestellt mit schnee ohne
dreck also relativ einfach zu bekommen
der ressourcen ein feuerzeug habe ich
glaube ich aufgebraucht und das liegt
irgendwo einer kiste drin
dann habe ich halt überall diese
geschenke hingestellt die man nur ein
bisschen brennen auch und so was hab ich
denn sonst fertig gestellt also ich hab
in meinem in meinem ruhm hier habe ich
eine
ein schildchen gesehen habe ich ein
schildchen gesehen von easy hatte darin
geschrieben darf ich bei dir wohnen dann
habe ich ihn einfach geantwortet ja klar
habe dir ein zweites bett für deine vier
meter beide direkt neben 1 gestellt luca
und jetzt habe ich hier noch irgendwie
nicht drüber das geschriebene blue card
mädchen und dieses mädchen aber okay
wenn auch nicht so wild gut das habe ich
dann auch gebaut sonst ich könnte mir
irgendwie farben hier ein bisschen
abholzen
aber sonst habe ich glaube ich gar
nichts gemacht so die farm ist abgeholzt
ich sag mal abgeholzt abgefahren
jedenfalls wollte ich halt in dieser
folge euch das mal eben zeigen was ich
gemacht habe ich war so ein bisschen auf
höhlentour hab so ein paar neue sachen
hier gebaut die ganz weihnachtlich aus
dem holz macht ihr alles wieder kaputt
sonst habe ich meine ich auch nichts
gemacht ich habe acht so ja ich habe
hier noch ein bisschen was gemacht und
habe ich einfach schnee hängen platziert
und hier oben an der decke auch dass ein
gewisser schnee gang ist dann dass das
hier halt so rüber geht in dieses ding
sondern steht hier quasi seine couch
oder kann man dann so weihnachtlich nach
draußen schauen das blöde zeit ist es
hier wegen der farm darüber die ganze
zeit ein bisschen am tropf ist aber
damit muss man natürlich leben hier
könnte ich rein theoretisch noch fenster
oder gemälde hin machen oder so aber das
könnt ihr ja auch ein theoretisch könnt
ihr das auch später machen und zwar ach
was ich noch gemacht hab ich mir bald
solche laternchen hingestellt hier
überall da gehe ich mal kurz im weg lang
damit ja mal wissen was von der welt
hier seht ihr könnt das auch theoretisch
noch modifizieren diese welt und
eventueller von screenshots hochladen
weil am 24
download link veröffentlicht ihr dann
diesen download link habt also den
werdet ihr das muss ich mich auch mal
sagen das will ich aber in der folge
übermorgen noch mal sagen jeder wenig
übermorgen einfach drauf eingehen am 24
das ganze ablaufen wird mit dem
download-link und die letzte finale
folge und so was alles sondern ich
wollte heute einfach mal so ein bisschen
habe mir vier alten die entrada lassen
also es ist halt so dass ich in dieser
folge wirklich mal eine ganz kurze folge
machen wollte unter zehn minuten
irgendwie ich wollte euch nur kurzzeitig
hatte weil diese sachen hier gebaut
screen euch vermissen offen auf dem
stand halten jetzt kann ich hier
theoretisch also ein paar hühnchen plan
es ist probleme haben wir gar nicht mehr
seitdem ich dann meine farm habt so
läuft das eigentlich und ich wollte euch
halt einfach nur die sachen zeigen die
ich hier gebaut hat also diese teile
oder diese dahin oder liebe geschenke
oder bei mir da unten oder bei mir im
zimmer das im holz hinter für sie so was
in die richtung
ich hoffe noch ein bisschen holz einfach
jetzt mal nebenbei erst mal wenn ich
eine runde jedenfalls wollte ich
eigentlich das eigentliche hauptthema
warum ich dieses video eigentlich mache
ist ich habe neue shirt designs und so
weiter und so fort die findet ihr auf
bit bit.ly / konz darf meine ich meine
das ist die adresse
da könnt ihr drauf klickt man dann
findet ihr das neue shirt
ich blende euch jetzt mal einfach
sondern die sein davon ein wie das ganze
aussieht und zwar habe ich mich also ein
gewisses beispiel an der amerikanischen
flagge genommen zwar wisst ihr ja alle
die amerikanische flagge mit den
streifen und so weiter und so fort wo
ich kann mit dem schwert doch kann ich
ein bisschen geld in die amerikanische
amerikanische flagge mit den streifen
und den standort habe ich mir ein
beispiel angenommen habe dass ein
bisschen vereinfacht bisschen weniger
streiten gemacht und wollte da er ich
wollte da erst jüngst an machen einfach
sondern anstatt diesem ziel was ihr da
seht wollte ich so einen schwarz-weißen
wille jacob dahin machen allerdings sah
das auf dem druck nicht so gut aus dann
habe ich mir gedacht das zeigt zwar so
wille job partymäßig aber es ist häufig
so haben wir so viele hasen alter was
ist los mit diesen viechern aber dann
hab ich mir das macht einfach einen zeh
hin
für kraft aber was ist das denn guck mal
da sind so coole teilchen dran das ja
süßes häusern
ich mache einfach mal so ein c dran für
kraft und das passt ganz gut weil das
genau diese drei streifen miteinander
verbindet also ich bin das design echt
cool es ist ganz simpel und das c steht
für konkreter klauen
jedenfalls war das eigentlich
eigentliche seite die ich dafür die
eigentliche sache die ich sagen wollte
was könnte ich denn jetzt noch machen
ich könnte mal rein theoretisch ich habe
hier so ein paar dinge hier ich könnte
man noch dass sich überhaupt etwas
gebaut hat und euch nicht nur die sachen
gezeigt habe mache ich mir mal wolle und
am rande die mit dem zeug hier und an
wieso bekomme ich kein gemälde und dann
setzen wir in die mitte die wolle und
dann haben wir auch schon gemälde und
die kam erst mal unten anbringen und
schauen wie das aussieht einfach nur
damit ich jetzt überhaupt noch mal
irgendetwas in dieser folge jetzt hier
gebaut habe 123456 da muss auf jeden
fall zwei breites becken so 6 dann muss
hier auch ein 2,2 mal muss die verfolgte
el gefällt mir an da wir noch zwei
gemälde haben könnte ich ja hier noch so
ein nein möchte hier hallo möchte hier
ja genau hier so ein kleines und hier
soll auch so ein kleines denkmal wie süß
jetzt haben wir sogar so ein kriegs und
ein paar gemälde ein paar hübsche sachen
ich glaube ich mache auch noch eben
einen zaun und mache wie geht man blumen
für minecraft minecraft wiki sagt okay
so geht eine falltür ok blumentopf ist
mehr zu krass dafür brauche ich ton und
die ganze scheiße ich mache das jetzt
einfach mal hier mit ich brauche ich
brauche ich brauche brauche bauen noch
einen einen einen setzling heute nämlich
einfach mal die mit anpacken und jetzt
auch mal ein bisschen hier
verschönerungsverein damit nicht
irgendjemand später sacken
inneneinrichtung ist ja wohl nicht oder
eine stärke setzen wir diese tollen
teilchen drauf dann setze ich hier im
pott in ihr sohn bot dann nehme ich mir
die tollen zäune die ich hier habe und
fackeln habe ich natürlich auch dann
mache ich nämlich das so hier und dann
setze ich hier noch das denken und dann
mache ich nehme ich noch hier ein
da kommt eine rolle einfach hin die
einen fernseher darstellen soll
ja und freunde damit würde ich auch
sagen was das für diese folge minecraft
fries ich bin jetzt doch hier in der
roda teil 13 minuten wahrscheinlich
werde ich sage herunter kürzen auf zehn
minuten oder so ich wollte eigentlich
sagen dass ich neue design habe ich
finds richtig coole können bestellen auf
bit.ly stuff es steht immer oben in der
beschreibung neue shirt designs und bla
ich würde mich freuen wenn du das
bestellen würde dich verdienen daran er
recht wenig aber es ist halt einfach so
ein bisschen sonne zusammenhalt merkmal
so wenn ich das shirt habe und ihr habt
das shirt ich habe meinen schon bestellt
ist es allerdings noch nicht da und es
kommt wahrscheinlich auch erst an wenn
ich aus dem urlaub zurück bin ich
jedenfalls würde ich sagen ich nehme mal
diese blöden blöden schildchen jetzt
hier mit
wenn es euch gefallen habe ich mich über
eine bewertung freuen wir sehen uns
wieder und zwar morgen bei dem minecraft
hacks oder übermorgen in der nächsten
folge minecraft fries dann würde ich
sagen bleibt fresh und ciao